(crowd applauds)
- So, good afternoon
everyone. My name is Ravesh.
I'm with Pega Systems,
and over the next 10, 15 minutes,
we're going to take you
down a little journey
of how AI is driving app modernization.
So, we'll start with legacy.
You know, if you've been in the
cloud modernization business
and you've been around for a while,
you'll notice that, or at least know that
85% of the workloads
have yet to move to the cloud, right?
Give or take, 80 to 85% of workloads
have not moved to the cloud.
This is a statistic used by AWS.
Now, if you think of why
have 85% of workloads
not yet moved to the cloud,
that's because you've got applications
that have been written
about 30, 40, 50 years ago.
The complex gnarly applications
where either the developers have retired
or you've got over a
million lines of code,
you don't understand the dependencies
between the application
logic and the data.
And some of these applications
are mission critical.
They require very high
level of availability,
and there's too much risk, right?
So when we think of legacy,
legacy transformation
or legacy modernization,
that's the addressable
opportunity, that 85%, right?
And maybe it's not 85%,
but it's the top 10% within that 85%,
which are ready for disruption,
for AI-driven disruption and
have not moved to the cloud.
And if you talk to clients, you know,
this is not something that clients
have just started to think about, right?
You know, there are clients
who have tried to modernize applications,
mainframe applications,
COBOL applications,
AS400 applications, and in the past,
these have all been very
human centric, right?
Labor driven, you know,
years, months of work
to really understand, analyze
code, reverse engineer them,
understand the data dependencies,
you know, understand
what the processes are,
understand the data,
so there's a lot of risk that
has been involved, right?
And sometimes, there are
regulatory requirements
that are in these applications
that we haven't understood.
So, what gives us the
confidence now, you know,
that, you know, in this world, you know,
where everything is AI,
what gives us the confidence
that we're now ready
to go attack these 85% of the applications
that have not moved to the cloud?
Now, if you just think
about what AI is doing today
and how AI is actually
being applied inside of IT,
this is a piece of work that
was done by McKinsey last year.
They presented this at
re:Invent last year,
and, you know, if you just
generally understand the SDLC,
the overall process, SDLC cycle of IT,
there's a lot of compression
that AI is driving, right?
According to McKinsey,
they think it's about 50%
of compression in the
overall IT life cycle.
And if you notice over the top,
where the biggest compression
is happening is right here.
It's what called design
and discovery, right?
A lot of the AI-driven
compression is happening
within design and discovery,
because we can now, you start to use AI
to really help us understand requirements,
look at applications, reverse engineer,
reverse analyze applications,
develop the forward-engineering plans,
develop forward-engineering test cases,
understand and help redefine
the business processes
from analog processes
to more digitally-native
business processes,
and then also discover
functionality, right?
There's a lot of that
compression that's happening,
which is where AI is
being put use to, right?
Some of you may have, you
know, looked at AWS Transform
or some of the other tools.
There's a lot of this tooling
that's happening on the analysis.
(crowd drones)
Now, you would think,
"Ravesh, if AWS is doing
AWS Transform, you know,
what is the role of Pega?
What is Pega trying to do here?" Right?
So, one of the things that
we have done, you know,
in the broader industry,
almost everybody is focused
on the analyze problem, right?
Analyze the legacy applications,
whether it's a COBOL application,
whether it's a Lotus Notes application,
whether it's a .NET application,
whether it's a Java application, right?
Most of the tools that are
there in the market today
are focused on analyze, right?
Pega is the only firm
that's actually focused
on the rewrite problem.
So, if you look at the overall value chain
from a client perspective, right,
if you're a large client,
an insurance client,
a banking client, a healthcare client,
and you want to modernize
these applications,
you've gotta focus on analyze, rewrite,
integrate and deploy.
Generally, that's sort
of the lifecycle, right?
So, where we fit in, where Pega fits in,
is we're focused on the rewrite.
If you can analyze it,
we can rewrite the application for you,
and our premise, our philosophy
is anchored around
three key dimensions of transformation.
One, we are in the business of
retiring legacy applications.
So, which means that we're going
to move from old architectures
to new cloud-native architectures.
So, that's the first degree
of of transformation.
The second degree of transformation
is we are moving from
programming languages
to no-code platforms.
Why is that important?
If you think about how business,
you know, business changes today, right,
there are continuous new
business requirements,
there are regulatory changes,
there are process changes,
there are supply chain changes,
so all of these changes require
business process change, right?
And you can rewrite an application
on a new programming language,
but six months from now,
that'll become legacy
because you would already
start to accumulate tech debt.
It's just the cycle, right?
So that is why we firmly
believe that, look,
part of our transformation
value proposition
is moving from application
languages to no-code platforms,
because then anytime there
is a business process change,
there's a regulatory change,
it's a configuration change.
It's not about requirements,
design, you know,
requirements, design, analysis.
It's a configuration change.
You can simulate the change using AI
and you can change your workflow.
So, that's the second
degree of transformation,
which is moving from application languages
to no-code platforms.
And the third degree of transformation
that is also happening
is you're moving from analog processes,
'cause a lot of processes, a lot of times
you have systems that are
talking to other systems,
orchestrating data,
orchestrating the flow of work
between your ERP system,
your fulfillment system,
your order management system.
So, you've got a lot of
orchestration that happens right?
Now, think about in the
modern agentic world,
do you really need that
or can agents start to
drive the orchestration
between different systems?
So, you're starting to
move from analog processes
where a lot of these point-to-point
connections were made
through all sorts of
integration technologies,
to where now you're using AI
to drive the agentic automation
across these workflows.
Yeah?
(crowd droning continues)
So, what we have done, Pega,
is we have built the tooling
to facilitate the modernization
of these legacy applications.
We call that technology Blueprint.
If you just look right behind you,
our booth is right down there, you know,
right where the AWS section ends here,
so you can actually go see our technology
and experience it in real time, right?
But what we are going to do is
in the next 10 minutes,
we're actually going to show
you the technology in action,
and if there is one thing,
one thing that you take away
from this little talk here,
it is A, B, C, anything
to Blueprint to cloud.
So, we're gonna show you
two examples of two app,
you know, one's a very
complex COBOL application
and one is more traditional
where you're doing
requirements, design, discovery,
and you're using those
documents, giving that to AI
and AI is going to build the
application for you, right?
So, just remember, anything
to blueprint to cloud. Yeah?
All right, so I'm gonna give it to Matt.
He's gonna walk you
through two demonstrations.
One, a first application
using requirements,
and then the second one using
AWS Transform, you know,
on a COBOL application.
- Cool.
- Yeah?
- All right.
Thank you, Ravesh. What's up, everybody?
Matt Healy. I lead go-to-market
for the Pega platform.
Just a couple minutes ago I
asked our team if I had any swag
I could throw out and they
handed me a bunch of pins.
I was like, "I can't throw pins
at these nice-looking people.
I'd end up on the news!"
So, you're welcome for that,
but yeah, to Ravesh's point,
let's go through a live demo
of what this transformation
process can actually look like.
So, bear with me and if
the network goes down,
we're all heading that way
and talking to the folks
who are responsible for this.
So, if you're not familiar with Pega,
it's a workflow automation
and AI-agent platform,
largely leveraged by large enterprises,
large government agencies
to automate their back-office processes,
their customer-service processes,
and their customer engagement.
Think marketing.
So obviously, at a large enterprise
who's been in business
for 50, 100, 150 years,
there's a lotta legacy in involved
in those areas of the business.
So, you know, we kept
getting requests like,
"Hey, what can you do
to help us, you know,
analyze information that we have available
and use that to transform
and reimagine those processes
into new cloud-native
applications on your platform,
which allow us to drive the
automation, the AI agents,
the experiences that
we're looking to deliver?"
So, that's where Blueprint comes in.
So, Blueprint is available to anyone.
You can even go try this
out after the session,
pega.com/blueprint,
and essentially, it has a set
of AI agents built into here
that allow enterprises
to bring different types
of information from
their existing processes,
their existing legacy estates,
and analyze that to extract
the business processes
and the data models needed
to then bring it to the cloud
and start to reimagine it.
So, let's say for example,
I was working at a government agency
and we hand out grants, we take
in applications for grants,
and then we disperse funds after
they go through an approval
and a validation cycle.
I might have a legacy system
that looks something like this.
You know, maybe it was built on .NET.
Maybe this is Lotus Notes,
maybe this is a home-grown,
you know, type application.
Maybe this is, you know, an
off-the-shelf application,
whatever it may be, but
I wanna get off of it.
So, I might have that video
and I might have some
more context available
in the form of documentation.
So here, I have a requirements
document sort of describing
the different aspects of that process.
What types of data,
what types of decisions
do we need to make throughout the process?
So, I can take those assets directly
without having to, you know,
go through any analysis by hand
and, you know, go through
the analysis the old way,
and import them into Blueprint,
and what Blueprint is gonna do
is it's gonna send the
different assets out to
each one of those AI agents.
For the video processing,
it's gonna listen
to the transcript, if
there's a walkthrough,
it's also gonna look at the screens
and it's gonna extract,
(crowd droning continues)
AWS, what's up?
(Ravesh chuckles)
(crowd droning continues)
So, it's gonna extract, ah!
Darn it! That's okay.
Well, I will go to one that
I created just before this,
if I even have wifi to begin with.
(crowd droning continues)
All right, so bear with me. Sorry.
We knew this was gonna happen.
So, essentially what Blueprint does
is it would have analyzed those assets,
extracted the business processes,
extracted the data models,
and extracted the people
involved in the process,
and it's gonna take that information
and build me a template that
I can then begin to adapt
and turn into a future-state
application on the cloud.
So, (chuckles) you know,
from there I can invite
all of my business and IT stakeholders.
I can have many different
people engaging on this palette,
and almost treat this like a,
like a whiteboard purpose-built
for business-process transformation.
So, we can all get in here and be like,
"All right, this is
where we're coming from.
Now, let's make this look
like where we wanna be
in the future. Let's
reimagine our processes."
We can dive into the steps of the process,
and, you know, get to some
really high-level fidelity
of the requirements of our
future-state application.
We can, you know, do that
for all of our workflows.
We can model out our data
and our integrations,
so, if we need to connect
to any back-end systems,
we can model that out in here as well.
Even going as far as importing
application integration assets
or data assets that we have.
So if I have a legacy
database, I wanna migrate
to the cloud, I can take
SQL and import it in here,
it will replicate the data
structures for the cloud,
or if I have third-party integrations,
which I need to replicate
with my new system,
I can take a YAML file,
an open API specification
and integrate that in here
and have that replicated as well.
I can then move on to the people
involved with the process.
So, who do I need to be thinking about
in terms of serving experiences
and different channels?
And, you know, dive into each
one of their requirements
in terms of, you know, what
they need to be able to do,
what security we need to
have available for them,
what they need to or should
be able to see, access,
and edit along their journey.
And, you know, at the end
of this Blueprint process,
this is something teams
would spend, I don't know,
half a day, a day, working on,
getting their business
subject-matter experts
and their IT teams, you know,
collaborating in this environment,
and at the end of it,
I have a comprehensive
requirements document, and that's cool.
And this was assisted by AI,
and one of the things that
our AI agents did in here
was actually go and do some
research on best practices
for the use case based on
what it is I am looking to automate,
but I can even take this,
what we call a blueprint,
the metadata from this application,
and deploy it to the cloud,
whether it be on AWS, on GCP,
or on my, you know,
self-managed environment,
and generate a cloud-native
application in,
it takes about five minutes.
So, I'm able to go from
Blueprint to the cloud,
something I can touch,
feel, execute, test,
in, you know, less than a day,
and, you know, along the
way, I can even preview
before I do any of that development work,
before I even touch the
cloud, I can preview
what my application is gonna look like,
how my workflows are gonna come to life
for the various sets of users who I
wanna make it available to.
So, this is what Pega's
out-of-the-box back-office
portal looks like.
So, I can see, you know,
how a claims adjudicator,
what their day would look like,
what their experience would look like,
what the forms that they
would have to complete
would look like, you know,
what dashboards they'd be able
to see and take a look at.
I can even take a look
at a mobile application.
You know, maybe I have
a Salesforce application
that I want to plug into.
I can take a preview of that here as well,
and, you know, one of the unique things
about Pega's architecture,
that is sort of core to our philosophy
is that business processes, workflows,
should be abstracted from channels,
so what you're seeing here
is the same claims adjudication workflow
plugged into multiple sets of
channels for multiple users.
So, it allows large
enterprises to serve, you know,
their customers directly,
their back-office teams,
their customer-service representatives,
give them all the same
capability to create work
and do work, you know, without having
to encode the business logic
in each and every channel
that they wanna deliver.
So, it unlocks increased agility
and decreased total cost of ownership
in these multi-channel environments,
but I can even, you know,
see what it would look
like if I did wanna embed
that workflow directly to a customer,
either through like a
form-based interaction
or through conversational self-service.
And this is where we get into AI agents,
which are all over the place,
so, as you can imagine,
we couldn't get off,
I think it's a tally,
we have to check the box
that we showed AI agents
before we got off stage,
so I'm gonna do that.
So, you know, one of the things,
because we have this approach
where workflows are
separated from channels,
you know, one of the things
that's natural in that
is extending workflows to
conversational self-service.
You wanna give people access to,
you know, get work done
through natural language.
And we heard Matt Garmin this
morning talk about the need
for predictability in
our AI agents as well,
so that's essentially how
we're approaching this.
This is what we call
predictable AI agents.
So, you'll notice I did no prompting.
I didn't configure an AI agent anywhere.
What happens in Pega is when
you build an application,
we automatically wrap all
of your business processes
with a conversational AI agent
and all that AI agent can
do is act as a concierge
to your pre-structured processes.
So, let me give you an example.
So, if I came in here and
be like, "I broke my leg
and need to file a claim."
It's gonna go, this agent,
look through all of the
workflows which I defined,
hopefully find the right
one if AWS is cooperating,
and it's gonna begin to walk
me through that same process,
which I had up on the
Business Process Palette page,
and it's gonna walk me
through collecting that data
so I can be like, "This was today,"
you know, "500 bucks. 400
bucks. Diagnosis negative."
(crowd droning continues)
I can't type, but you get the idea.
And the whole time, any
interaction that I'm having-
With this AI agent-
- It's over 15 minutes.
- [Matt] Is tracked as a case,
(Ravesh speaks faintly)
as an instance of a workflow,
the same as if I submitted
it through the website,
the same as if a
customer-service representative
filled it out on my behalf,
so it gives me that
control, that confidence
in deploying AI agents at scale.
Let me actually take this as
well. I'm running outta time.
I got 15 seconds, so I did
wanna show one more thing.
So obviously, you know,
we're talking a lot
at re:Invent here about
getting off of the mainframe.
So, one of the other things
that we've done in here
is integrated Blueprint with
AWS Transform as an AI agent.
- [Ravesh] Okay.
- [Matt] So, I can have
a mainframe application,
go through the Transform process
to build that deep
understanding of what's in that,
which you see here, and then
we've built an AI agent,
which actually runs in Transform
and translates that analysis
from that mainframe system
into information which can actually go
and create that blueprint
that we were just looking at.
So, I can go and kick that
process off automatically
and then begin to go from
mainframe to something my business
and IT teams can collaborate on,
and begin to reimagine,
rethink, to the cloud,
and deploy that in just
a couple seconds here.
And we're getting the hook,
but, you know, we would love
if you swung over to the booth,
it's like 45 steps that way.
Come saw a demo, talked a
little bit more in depth
and booth 366, so don't miss it.
Thank you for your time.
- Yeah.
(crowd member cheers)
(crowd applauds)
- That mainframe application,
just so that, it is running Transform
and building the cloud-native application
based on the extraction, is
less than two weeks using AI.
So that's...
(crowd member laughs)
- Thank you.